l'accueil maintenant valérie lemercier
ça va pas mal est ce que pour vous la
fellation est une chose naturelle dans
le groupe sait pas ce que c'est c'est
bien ce que je disais la nature telle
attaque bille en tête 10 antennes et
voilà alors vous êtes déjà vu dans cette
émission nous raconter votre vie la
drogue la prostitution fille vit on va
pas recommencer à chaque fois je vais
simplement rappeler un petit peu votre
passé qui est brillant valérie lemercier
vous avez grandi à gonfreville en
seine-maritime avec trois soeurs départ
en exploitant agricole à 18 ans vous
monter à paris vous fait le
conservatoire et des petits boulots
comme vendeuse aux galeries lafayette
nous a beaucoup aidés par la suite pour
caricaturer les gens vous débutez au
piano zinc un bar homosexuel du marais
et puis vous commencez à faire des one
man show de la télévision du cinéma pour
un premier one man show vous obtenez un
molière en télévision ou fait lady
palace dans la série 2 de jean michel
ribes au cinéma milou en mai avec louis
malle les visiteurs le numéro un vous
obtenez un césar du meilleur second rôle
vous refusez le second mais vous faites
un album avec bertrand burgalat et
ensuite vous commencez à réaliser des
films de pub et puis des films de cinéma
dont le génial le derrière qui
caricaturent la gauche caviar gay et là
vous obtenez pour troisième one man show
une récompense qui est encore un molière
voilà
puis on commet
c'est l'abandon
on peut encore
bien où en sont vos rapports avec la
promotion à la télévision ça va je suis
là vous dites on ne pose jamais les
bonnes questions
non il ya des mauvaises surtout peut-on
rire de tout oui il du bien de rien avec
ce qui se passe en ce moment oui c'est
vrai c'est vrai que sa troisième guerre
mondiale j'ai vu un
alors donc vous êtes ici pour votre
troisième one man show celui qui a été
pendant six mois aux folies bergères et
qui maintenant part en tournée en
province avec un olympia l'olympia c'est
du 11 au 15 décembre et la tournée c'est
dans toute la france jusqu'en mars 2002
puis en tournée en ce moment ouais c'est
comment faire avec les mains je sais pas
6 novembre à clermont-ferrand dans le 63
le 8 à li shi sait dans quoi vichy je ne
sais pas le 9 à nevers dans le coin à
neuf et aller vers le 10 à bourges à
bourges fait bouge chez les bourges et
après en belgique en belgique bien sûr à
liège à bruxelles
voilà mais regardez à quoi ça ressemble
mallet lozère on enlevait sa culotte et
bien je m'appelle son vin kouté j'ai 19
ans je suis élève dans une école de
tourisme j'ai inscrit mes le shass un
stage dans le milieu
non mais avant cela m'arrive aussi de
m'amuser un petit je sais ce que c'est
que l'humour ouvrage pratique c'est pas
vous garder ouverte la drogue
c'est un projet dans ce que tu sais qui
c'est vrai que juliette c'est juliette
juliette de roméo juliette
en fait elle aime part au mieux un nom
parce que sa grande soeur de ma copine
daphné elle dit qu'en fait elle fait
l'amour avec le chanteur d'ali baba
bien des habitants comarch à mort dont
foot et je n'ai pas besoin de faire de
la promo très bien je suis très contente
d'être parti en tournée
ouais c'est tout ce que tu détestes
d'habitude de combat de nuit c'est tout
ce que je déteste simplement il ya un
tel décalage c'est à dire que on a
tellement pas d'image qui ont fini par
passer des trucs où je suis en train de
doubler tarzan ou comme ça que c'est
d'ailleurs très mauvaise qualité ce
qu'on vient de voir c'est juste mon
petit caméscope qui a filmé un soir aux
folies bergères donc j'en ai assez des
petits vous mais c'est vrai qu'il n'ya
pas de cas c'est qu'il n'y a pas de
spectacle n'est pas filmé oui c'est ça
ça vous fait jamais de cassettes de vos
spectacles n'y aura pas de trace non il
y en a 2 aucun des trois camps vous
serez mort tu auras plus rien voilà il y
aura plus rien
ok c'est comme ça c'est la vie
alors c'est un spectacle est très au
point des textes très ciselée très très
juste autour d'une douzaine de
personnages qui ont tous un point commun
c'est d'être des victimes on peut dire
non un peu mal barré arias le personnage
typique lemercier la burj catho qui
ramassent des cormorans mazoutés capelle
sa soeur bene ça c'est un bel hymne
lille ça c'est un classique
oui c'est à dire que j'avais pas fait
dans le précédent de bourges comme ça
mais la gelée reprise ça m'amusait de la
mettre dans un autre contexte de la m en
bretagne c'est surtout qu'elle a une
soeur qui est très dépressive et qu'elle
est très méchant
ouais il ya une vieille des français je
nettoie ses joueurs non on l'a droguée
où elle est assez jeune et elle est
c'est fait stériliser en avril 95 pour
ses parents mais bon ça allait mal barré
une paysanne une prof de danse russe une
étudiante très méchante et puis des
passages en string comme on vient de
voir l'un belge veut accessible narre le
belge veuf qui incombe à son fils
comment sa mère était bonne ouais ouais
fait rire ça les gens géniaux mais c'est
à dire que c'est très drôle d'ailleurs
parce que je suis en tournée depuis un
mois
plus je suis dans le nord plus ça parle
aux gens c'est à dire à manger des gens
j'ai joué à maubeuge l'autre jour c'est
vrai que les gens sont très près de la
belgique dans toutes les expressions
beige
donc j'ai hâte de le jouer à bruxelles
en belgique
vous n'êtes toujours pas mariés vous non
plus non celle au-delà
mais qu'est-ce que vous avez des fils et
plus de mecs
non c'est vrai il ya plus de main
jusqu'à zélés bien il reste que les
bonbons là nous marquons vous allez
faire c'est jamais vous marier mais si
j'aimerais bien mais je sais pas fini
ouais voulait lancer un appel à la télé
non pas du tout non surtout pas non
c'est sûr parce que c'est quand ça
marche on conçoit des nombreux un noyau
mais je vais non mais c'est bon aussi
j'ai reçu une lettre aujourd'hui on me
demandait des photos avec des tas de
tenues différentes
est-ce que vous pouvez mettre des tas de
tenues différentes et moi envoyer les
photos non non mais je fais pas
d'annoncer maintenant offert non plus
non ça va ça va venir tout ça doit venir
tout seul
on l'a bien
ans